christoph hat bereits 15 Bundesländer
durch jetzt fragen wir noch mal lieber
Christoph wie erlebst du den heutigen
Tag hier in Berlin ja ich bin ziemlich
durch schon gesagt und ich weiß sind 16
Bundesländer bist du sicher ich habe
jetzt in eruck es kommen noch 16
hinterher und wir haben 32
Bundesländer ich glaube da IRST du dich
weil wir z.B zu zweit ein Bundesland
repräsentieren da kommt man dann schnell
auf die Idee genau dass man das
verdoppelt so jetzt müsst ihr mal sagen
weil ich ja so durch bin für welches
Bundesland an für Thüringen für
Thüringen für schöne Thüringen und ihr
kommt auch wirklich daher ich auf jeden
Fall gebürtinger Thüringer und Rio ist
zugezogen zugezogener okay okay wo
wohnst du in Thüringen in Erfurt in der
Landeshauptstadt in der landeshauptstad
da wohnen wahrscheinlich die meisten
Menschen wen alle
da also ein kleines Ländle im schönen
Osten und was hat euch hierher
verschlagen in diese große Metropole zu
diesem wahnsinnig riesigen Wettbewerb na
ja wir haben es irgendwie nicht so
verstehen können warum Thüringen auf den
zweiten Platz gerutscht ist nun dadurch
dass Berlin zweimal gewonnen hat haben
wir gedacht komm her wir machen das
beide zusammen wir Ruppen das und all
time number one da müssen wir hin wie
auf dem zweiten Platz gerutscht ach so
in der Gesamtwertung es gibt ja so eine
Gesamtwertung welches Land am häufigsten
gewonnen hat ist demnach auch an erster
Stelle ges punktzahlil Thüring schon mal
gewonnen nee stimmt das fällt mir gerade
auf ganz
knapp
deswegen
vielleicht sollten wir da noch mal
drüber reden und türingen war aber
obwohl es nicht gewonnen hat die ganze
Zeit auf Platz 1 in dieser Gesamtwertung
und durch Peter Fox der da letztes Jahr
noch mal an die
Lichtregie ja können wir noch mal das
Licht
haben wir machen doch das Interview
danke schön vielen Dank zu nett aber
immer noch ein bisschen dunkel noch
wieder wieder alte Alter
statusuch aber
ah vielen Dank super super es wäde
gottprache es werde Licht und es war wo
waren wir stehen geblieben gesamtk
gesamtwer Platz 1 da waren wir stehen
geblieben und ja das ist eigentlich so
vielleicht die Hausaufgabe jetzt den
ersten Platz auch zu holen nach
Thüringen habt ihr denn so eine riesige
Halle überhaupt in Thüringen oder muss
das dann in der Schulaula stattfinden
doch doch ja die Messehalle die
Messehalle
12500 pas ja gut also das geht da könest
be buisokos machen und spricht 32 Länder
an einem Tag dann durch nein ich habe
jetzt glaub ich nein aber es war super
es war super es sind es ist ein hart
umkämpftes Feld das muss man sagen nach
allem was ich gehört habe im Interview
und auch als
musikalische Ergebnisse wie sieht es bei
euch aus was rechnet euch aus habt ihr
Chancen auf den ersten Platz für uns ja
wir stehen ja auf dem Plakat ganz unten
wir sind die letzten die du heute
interviewen musst darfst dar darf darf
natürlich
für uns ist super dass wir so ein großes
Publikum hier bespielen können und mit
unserer Musik erreichen können und
vielleicht ein paar Prozent abknabbern
insofern ist das dabei sein olympisch
gedacht schon ein Gewinn für uns und mal
gucken also das Feedback auf den Song
planlos das Video ist seit zwei Wochen
erst online der Song kurz vorher erst
und wir bekommen Klicks und ich hoffe es
werden paar mehr jetzt wird's
interessant wie ist es nach dem morgigen
Abend was passiert dann überhaupt es ist
aber auch interessant was bei uns
passiert denn wie immer wenn ihr planlos
von den beiden sensationell findet dann
also für dieses Video voten thumbs up es
favorisieren und so oft gucken wie es
nur geht dann haben wir denke ich am
Freitag vor der Sendung schon einen
kleinen Trend
jo und was wünscht ihr euch von den
Youtube
Zuschauern von den Youtube ja sind jetzt
ja vor allen Dingen Youtuber also das
was du schon gesagt hast genau guckt
euch an wir hoffen es gefällt euch und
wenn es euch gefällt dann wie gesagt
Daumen drauf Daumen drüber Daumen
drücken und Kön könnich auch gerne
anrufen für uns Woten und dann hört ihr
auch unsere tollen
Stimmen und die sagen euch dann danke
schön richtig SMS geht auch habe ich
gehört SMS gibt auch geht auch und es
soll noch Tickets geben also soll noch
ein paar Plätze geben und wenn wenn wir
die Halle ihr habt die Halle auch
gesehen gigantische Show oderelaufen
gigantische Show wir haben schon
feuerspäne ne wie sagt man Feuer Funken
funkenschläge gesehen und riesige
Flammen und es war auf einmal sehr warm
und wir sind gespannt was so mit uns
passiert hoffentlich werdet ihr nicht
geröstet hoffen wir WE mit rösten können
wir uns ja aus
neoh Stefan mag anscheinend Kaffee nicht
so das heißt vielleicht bringt man ihm
das L als Tipp für alle die mal zum
bundeswision Fahren Kaffee ist so ein
Fragezeichen bei Stefan vielleicht mal
mit Tee versuchen oder auch Wasser gut
viel Erfolg vielen dankr Danke dir danke
euch tschüss